- Our minds are designed
to stop you at all costs
from doing anything that might hurt you.
If you notice that you
daydream about being a writer,
if you notice that you daydream
about starting a tech company,
if you notice you daydream
about building bridges,
follow your curiosity.
So if it were easy to get
what you wanted in life,
Google would have all
ready figured out an app.
- She's an American
speaker, TV personality,
coach, and author.
Her TEDx talk on how to
stop screwing yourself over
has over 10 million views on YouTube.
Her book, Stop Saying You're
Fine is a business best seller.
She's Mel Robbins, and
here's my take on her top 10
rules to success.
Also guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates with
you, please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be
inspired by your sharing,
and also when you write it
down, you're much more likely
to lock it in for yourself too.
Enjoy.
(intense deep music)
(strong inspiring music)
- We bought into this complete
falsehood that at some
point, you're going to have
the courage, at some point
you're going to have the confidence,
and it's total bull (beep) frankly.
Are we allowed to swear on this show?
- Absolutely.
- Okay.
It's complete garbage and
so there are so many people
in the world and, you know,
you may be watching this
right now and you have
those incredible ideas,
and what you think is
missing is motivation,
and that's not true because
the way that our minds are
wired, and the fact that
human beings is that we
are not designed to do things
that are uncomfortable,
or scary, or difficult.
Our brains are designed to
protect us from those things,
because our brains are
trying to keep us alive.
And in order to change, in
order to build a business,
in order to be the best
parent, the best spouse,
to do all those things that
you know you want to do with
your life, with your
work, with your dreams,
you're going to have to do
things that are difficult,
uncertain, or scary.
Which sets up this problem for all of us,
you're never going to feel
like it, motivation's garbage.
You only feel motivated to
do the things that are easy,
right?
- Why do you think that is?
- Oh, I know exactly why
that is because I've studied
this so much because, for
me, one of the hardest things
to figure out was why is it so
hard to do the little things
that would improve my life.
And what I've come to realize,
and what we'll talk a lot
about today, is that the way
that our minds are designed
is our minds are designed
to stop you at all costs
from doing anything that might hurt you,
and the way that this all
happens is it all starts
with something super subtle,
that none of us ever catch,
and that is with this
habit that all of us have
that nobody's talking about.
We all have a habit of hesitating.
We have an idea, you're
sitting in a meeting,
you have this incredible
idea, and instead of just,
you know, saying it, you
stop and you hesitate.
Now, what none of us realize
is that when you hesitate,
just that moment, just that micro moment,
that small hesitation, it
sends a stress signal to your
brain, it wakes your
brain up and your brain
goes all of a sudden
goes oh, wait a minute,
why is he hesitating?
He didn't hesitate when he put
on his killer spiky sneakers,
he didn't hesitate with the
really cool track pants,
he didn't hesitate with the NASA teacher.
Now he's hesitating to
talk, something must be up.
So then your brain goes
to work to protect you.
It has a million different
ways to protect you,
one of them is called
the spotlight effect,
it's a known phenomenon where
your brain magnified risk.
Why, to pull you away from
something that it perceives
to be a problem.
And so, you can truly
trace every single problem,
or complaint, in your life
to silence and hesitation.
Those are decisions.
And what I do, and what's changed my life,
is waking up and realizing
that motivation's garbage,
I'm never going to feel like
doing the things that are tough,
or difficult, or uncertain,
or scary, or new,
so I need to stop waiting
until I feel like it.
And number two, I am one
decision away from a totally
different marriage, a
totally different life,
a totally different job, a
totally different income,
a totally different
relationship with my kids.
Not like one decision, I'm divorcing you,
in the marriage example, but
one decision on, you know,
you could be having a
conversation with your spouse
and you feel your emotions rise up,
and within a tiny window,
those emotions can take over
and can impact how your marriage goes.
Or you can learn how to take
control of that micro moment,
and make a decision to
act in a way that actually
shifts your marriage.
Your life comes down to your decisions,
and if you change your decisions,
you will change everything.
When I was 22, right after
I graduated from Dartmouth,
I was so focused on making everyone happy,
that I almost chose the
worst possible career
for my personality.
It's not a bad career,
it just could've been horrendous for me.
I was interested in the
environment, so I decided,
oh yeah, I'll go get a law degree.
And then I'll go work in
Washington, and I think maybe
I'll work on environmental
policy, and I'd probably
end up in some cube farm.
And everyone was thrilled
with the plan, everyone,
it turns out, but me.
So here I am, I'm driving
a U-Haul across country to
go to law school and to get a
degree in environmental law,
and something started to gnaw at me.
And with every single mile that I drove,
my thoughts were getting louder,
and doubts were starting to pour in.
My gut was telling me, Mel,
turn the damn U-Haul around,
but the problem was that
everything was all ready in place.
I mean, I'm all ready in the U-Haul,
the thing is all ready
packed, I'm all ready 10 miles
into my drive, the
tuition had been paid for
the first semester, I had signed a lease.
I mean, I could not undo these things.
Isn't that why it's so difficult
for you to make changes
in your life?
Because you think that
things can't be undone?
The fact is any excuse you
come up with you can undo.
Tuition can be reimbursed,
apartments can be leased,
plan B can be invented.
So I got up, I repacked that U-Haul,
and I drove out of town.
I let myself make a U turn in life.
If you ever find your
gut battling your head,
save yourself the drama.
I guarantee you your gut is right.
Guarantee you your excuses can be undone,
and I guarantee you you can
make a U turn in your life
right now if you want to.
You can be asking for assignments
that are above your level.
So there's work that you do at your level,
and then there's work that
you do above your level.
And the only way that you're
going to be promoted to do
work above your level is
A, if you can demonstrate
that you're capable of doing
the work at your level,
and B, if you are proactive
in seeking out opportunities
that expand your capability
and give you a chance to
work above the level that you're at.
Nothing's going to happen unless
you take that initial action.
Nothing's going to happen,
nothing's going to change
unless you put down
that pen in the meeting
and you sit up and you pay attention,
and you listen for your
opportunity to speak.
Nothing's going to happen unless
you push yourself to go in
and make the ask for that
assignment that scares you
to death.
One night Chris had gone to
bed, I'd been struggling,
struggling, struggling.
We still had all the same
problems, we still had a lean
on the house, still facing bankruptcy,
still fighting like crazy,
I was still unemployed,
they still hadn't figured
out the solution yet
for the business, and I was
about to turn off the TV,
and there on the TV, there
was this rocket launching,
and I though oh my gosh, that is it!
I am going to launch myself
out of bed like a rocket ship,
like NASA, right here!
Had launched me out of that bed,
and I'm going to move so fast
that I don't think.
I'm going to beat my brain.
Now here's a really interesting point,
I talk a lot about your
instincts and inner wisdom.
And we can get into
this a little bit later,
but a lot of us talk about
the fact that you have a gut
feeling, but what all this
research that I've done
for the book and all
the speaking that I do,
what I've discovered that's
fascinating is actually,
when you set goals, when
you have an intention on
something that you want
to change about your life,
your brain helps you.
What it does is it opens up
a checklist and then your
brain goes to work trying
to remind you of that
intention that you set.
And it's really important
to develop this skill,
and I say that work purposefully,
the skill of knowing
how to hear that inner wisdom
and that intention kicking in,
and leaning into it quickly.
So for me, my brain saying
that's it, right there,
move as fast as a rocket, Mel.
I wanted to change my life,
and I think most people that
are miserable, or that are
really like dying to be great,
and dying to have more, we want to change,
we want to live a better
life, we want to create more
for our families, we want to be happier.
The desire is there, again,
it's about how do you
from knowledge to action.
So the first thing in this
story that's important
is realizing that the answer was in me,
and my mind was telling me pay attention.
It could have also been the bourbon.
(people laughing)
I had a couple manhattans that night.
Anyway, the next morning,
the alarm goes off and
I pretended NASA was there.
It's the stupidest story,
I literally went five,
four, three, two, one.
I counted out loud and then I stood up.
I'll never forget standing
there in my bedroom,
it was dark, it was cold,
it was winter in Boston.
And for the first time in three months,
I had beaten my habit of
hitting the snooze button.
I couldn't believe it, and
I thought wait a minute,
counting backwards, that
is the dumbest thing
I've ever heard in my entire life.
Well the next morning I
used it again, it worked.
The next morning I used
it again and it worked.
And then I started to notice
something really interesting,
there were moments all
day long, all day long,
just like that five second moment in bed,
where I knew knowledge what I should do.
And if I didn't move within five seconds,
my brain would step in
and talk me out of it.
Every human being has
a five second window,
it might even be shorter for you.
You have about a five second
window in which you can
move from idea to action
before your brain kicks into
full gear and sabotages
any change in behavior.
Because remember, your
brain is wired to stop you
from doing things that are
uncomfortable, or uncertain,
or scary.
It's your job to learn how
to move from those ideas
that could change everything
into acting on them.
I think you have to be really
in tune with your impulses
and with your natural state of curiosity.
And your curiosity, and the
things that you're naturally
drawn toward, that's the guide.
If you could spend hours
singing, if you could spend hours
baking, if you could spend hours writing,
if you could spend hours learning code,
that's a huge signal that
that's something that you're
really innately interested in.
And so if you're curious about something,
if you notice that you
daydream about being a writer,
daydream about starting a tech
company, if you notice you
daydream about building bridges,
follow your curiosity, and you
can do that a number of ways.
First of all, Google it.
There are millions and
millions of pages out there on
the web that are related to
what you're interested in.
Secondly, find an online course.
Most of the major universities
are offering their courses
online for free.
Third, buy a book about it.
Put yourself in a collision
course with the thing that
you're curious about, and you
will get closer and closer
and closer to figuring it out.
- What about when someone
can't realize or identify
their own negative feelings,
someone that has been
conditioned to (mumbles)
negative feelings and
believes that that's normal.
This question comes from Basana Denigaga.
- It is your normal, you're
right, it's a really...
First of all, I'm sorry that
that's been your experience
of life because that really stinks,
and it doesn't have to be that way.
But here's where I want you
to go, it's interesting about
what you said is the fact that
these feelings are normal.
Normal just means you're used to them,
but you don't have to live with them.
So even though you're so used
to these negative feelings,
and these feelings of doubt,
you still don't like them,
you still have the ability to stop that.
So I want you to think of
a moment in time when you
were really happy, like
it could be a memory from
being little, it could be
something that you dream
of doing.
And I want you to come up
with something really specific
about that moment.
Like, think about what you were wearing,
or think about the blue sky.
That's going to be where
I pointer anchor thought.
Every time, from this moment
forward, that you wake up,
or you find yourself drifting
to those normal feelings
of I'm a loser, I'm worthless,
I'm never going to find love.
They may be things that
you're used to thinking,
but that doesn't matter
because you can change them.
The second that you feel
that, you've drifted over into
that thought, and I keep
coming over here because
when you start using that (mumbles),
you're going to start to
literally feel which part
of the mind you're using.
The worries kind of happen here.
I want you to five, four, three, two, one,
and then I want you to insert
this vision of yourself,
this vision of yourself
where you felt really good.
And if you can't think of one, invent one.
How would you feel if you were in love?
How would you feel if you loved yourself?
How would you feel if you
did that thing that you're
scared of that you keep
talking yourself out of it?
That's your anchor thought.
Now, when you first start using the rule,
particularly when you're breaking a habit,
a habit of thinking negative thoughts.
When you first start doing
it, you may need to use
the five second rule 73 times in one day.
That's okay, I had to do it
like that when I was first
using the rule to cure myself of anxiety.
When I would start to
worry about anything,
I'd start to worry about my
kids, or I'd start to worry
about money, and I'd
feel my thoughts drift,
and then I'd start to feel my heart race.
I would stabilize my thoughts,
five, four, three, two, one.
I'd activate my prefrontal
cortex, lower the worries,
you know, on the other side,
and then I would start to
think about something that
actually made me feel really calm
or excited.
That is the battle of your mind.
And you know, the other thing
about normal that I just
want to say is that the reason
why it feels normal to doubt
yourself and to have low
self worth is because you've
thought this so long.
It's become a pattern, just
like chewing your nails
becomes a pattern or behavior
that you don't think about.
Well, the cool thing is
that based on science,
you can actually change any pattern,
even a thinking one.
So use the five second rule,
every single time you catch
yourself thinking the nasty
stuff and then activate
your prefrontal cortex,
and force yourself to think
something positive.
Every single morning, Monday
through Friday's at 9:00 AM,
I host a live call in radio
show on Sirius Satellite Radio.
It's called Make it
Happen with Mel Robbins.
And the thing that's been
so crazy about that show is
every single person that
calls me on that show,
they call in because they're
feeling stuck in their lives,
and they're resigned about
their ability to change
their lives.
And I'm not talking about
people that are nuts,
I'm talking about successful
people, like you and me,
that just somehow got
stuck in their lives.
And I'm not talking about
people that are looking
for cheesy self help, I'm
talking about people that really
want to figure out how to
move themselves forward.
And you know, I find that
so many of us think that our
dreams are unreachable, or unrealistic,
and it's just so sad.
I mean, people think that
their dreams disappear,
and if that's what you
think, congratulations,
you're officially stuck.
And the truth is that our
dreams are always there,
and they don't ever give up
on us, we give up on them.
But here's the secret, if
you just force yourself,
and I mean force because I
know damn well none of you
want to do anything about this,
and I also know you're sitting
there like, yeah, this self
help crap, this isn't for me.
But if you just force yourself
to take a couple small steps,
there's always a surprise.
So let's talk about Starbucks.
Starbucks, in 2008, very
interesting thing happened,
and many of you, if you were
in the financial services
market then probably know
this, that they're net income
decreased by about 28% that year.
At the time, they had 16,000
stores in 44 countries,
and they had gone through
this massive explosive growth
segment, in terms of going from public in,
I think it was like 1992,
they only had a 125 stores,
and now here we are
2008, they've got 16,000.
So what ends up happening
is Howard Schultz,
who was the chairman of the
board, comes back in as the CEO.
Very complex situation, right?
You've got operations in 44 countries,
you've got massive reductions
in terms of the profits
that you have, you've got the
stock market in Wall Street
screaming at you, you've
got customers that are going
to Dunkin Donuts because there's
a recession that's hitting.
So what do you do?
Well, he was very clear,
again, back to the two rules.
What do I stand for?
Like, what am I doing?
And what do I want the outcome to be?
So, he was very clear that
what he stood for as a leader
and what Starbucks should stand for is
the Starbucks experience.
He wanted to go back to the beginning and
reintroduce people to the romance
of having a cup of coffee.
Because you know, that's
how Starbucks launched
in the beginning, that he
was traveling and was over
in Italy, and was like, god,
why don't we have places
like these great stops to
have a little cup of coffee
over in the United States.
Boom, Starbucks, an idea,
it's born, it's launched.
So he decides he's going to
do whatever he can to get
the romance of having
a cup of coffee back.
In life, in any situation,
whether you're talking about
growing your company,
growing your bank account,
getting in a relationship,
getting out of a relationship,
getting something done at
the school system that your
kids are going to, on behalf of your kids.
Whatever it is that you're up to in life,
this is the only question
that you need to ask yourself,
what is it that I want.
Because the truth of the matter
is if you can answer that,
you can have it.
So, if it were easy to get
what you wanted in life,
Google would have all
ready figured out an app.
You would just type in,
okay, I'm a student,
and I want to go from being a
student to being successful.
And Google would tell you
go to college, then you get
your masters, then you
land this killer job,
and then you put in a bunch
of Facetime while you're
checking Facebook, then
you get promoted to manager
and you realize management
people kind of stink,
so then you keep climbing
the corporate ladder.
And then you start to wonder,
well, how did I end up here?
And then you're like, is
this what success looks like?
You're like, no, I'm
going to go to J Hilburn,
that's what success looks like.
(audience cheering)
So keep this in mind, if
there's something that you want,
like seven people, or a trip to Africa,
or you're going to make it to Mexico,
in the pink shirt, I'm
looking at you again, sorry.
I'm watching you, I'm routing for you.
Keep in mind this, here you
are, this is what you want.
I spend a lot of time on the cross fields,
although they don't really look like this.
You tend to think that what you want,
you just march right towards it.
But if in sports, you march
right towards the goal,
what happens?
The defenders come in, and
what the defenders are is
it's your brain saying,
ain't going to happen.
So the second you start moving
toward that thing you want,
be ready, you're going to tell
yourself you don't feel like it.
You're going to have to force
yourself, it's happening,
there's no way to get around it.
So what you're going to have to
do is you're going to basically
get bounced around a
lot, all over the place.
And there are going to be a
lot of times that you feel
like this was a really dumb
idea to start this business,
because it's going to get hard.
And I want to remind you about something.
Unlike the sports field where
there's an in and out of
bounds, the great thing
about life is there actually
aren't any.
And it's usually in those
moments when you feel like
you can't do it, that you're
closer than ever to having
everything that you wanted.
And I wanted to show you
this so that you keep in mind
because I think a lot of
times when you look back,
it's the darkest moments
where you realize holy cow,
that's what projected me forward.
We live in the most
amazing moment in time.
So that thing that you have
up here, whatever it may be,
you want to use healthy
eating to cure your diabetes,
you want to figure out how
to take care of the elders
and start a new hospice center,
you want to move to Africa
and build a school, guess what?
You could walk into a bookstore
right now and buy at least
10 books written by credentialed experts
on how the hell you do it.
You could Google it and you
could probably find at least,
I don't know, a thousand
blogs documenting the step,
by step, by step transformation
that somebody else
is all ready doing.
You can find anybody online
and cyber stalk them.
(audience laughing)
You can just walk in
their footsteps and...
You know, just use the
science of drafting,
follow whatever everyone else has done,
because someone else
is all ready doing it.
So why don't you have what
you want when you have
all the information that you need,
you have the contacts that you need?
There are probably free tools
online that allow you to
start a business, or join
a group, or do whatever
the heck you want.
It all comes down to one word.
(people laughing)
Shut the front door, you
know what I'm talking about.
(audience laughing)
The F bomb, it's everywhere.
You hear it all the time, and
I honestly don't understand
what the appeal is over the word.
I mean, you don't sound
smart when you say it,
and it's really not expressing
how you really feel.
It's sort of a cheap,
you know, shock to take,
and of course you know I'm
talking about the word fine.
(people laughing)
How you doing?
I'm fine.
Oh, really, you are?
Dragging around those extra
40 pounds, you're fine?
Feeling like roommates with
your spouse, you're fine?
You haven't had sex in four
months, you're fine, really?
I don't think so.
But see, here's the deal
with saying that you're fine,
it's actually genius
because if you're fine,
you don't have to do anything about it.
But when you think about this word fine,
it just makes me so angry.
I mean, here we are at a
conference about being alive
and you're going to describe
the experience of being alive
as fine, what a flimsy and feeble word.
If you're crappy, say you're crappy.
If you're amazing, say you're amazing.
Tell the truth.
And this not only goes
for the social construct.
Oh, I don't want to burden
you with the fact that I hate
my life, or hey, I'm
amazing but that would make
you feel terrible.
(people laughing)
The bigger issue with fine is
that you say it to yourself.
That thing that you want, I guarantee you,
you've convinced yourself that
you're fine not having it.
That's why you're not pushing yourself.
It's the areas in your
life where you've given up,
where you've said, oh, I'm
fine, my mind's never going to
change so I just can't
have that conversation.
I'm fine, you know, we
got to wait until the kids
graduate before we get
divorced, so we'll just sleep
in separate bedrooms.
I'm fine, I lost my job,
I can barely pay my bills
but whatever, it's hard to get a job.
And you know, one of the
reasons why this word also just
annoys me so much is
scientists have calculated...
Oh yeah, I'm coming down.
Scientists have calculated
the odds of you being born.
That's right, they've
crunched the numbers.
I see you up there.
(audience laughing)
They've crunched the numbers on you,
yeah, you guys standing up,
you want to sit down for this.
They've crunched the
numbers on you being born,
and they took into account all of the wars
and the natural disasters,
and the dinosaurs,
and everything else.
And do you realize that the odds,
the odds of you, yeah, right
here, put your computer away,
stand up for me, Doug.
(people laughing)
So the odds of Doug here, turn
around, say hi to everybody.
- Hello.
- The odds of Doug, Doug
being born at the moment
in time he was born to the
parents you were born to,
with he DNA structure that
you have, one in 400 trillion.
Isn't that amazing?
- [Doug] I'm so lucky.
- Yes!
(audience laughing)
You're not fine, you're fantastic.
You have life changing ideas for a reason,
and it's not to torture yourself.
Thank you, thank you, Doug.
(audience applauding)
You know, Christina's right
when she said all of you
could be on stage, because all of you,
we're all in this category.
One in 400 trillion.
All day long you have ideas
that could change your life,
that could change the world,
that could change the way
that you feel, and what
do you do with them?
Nothing.
Hopefully I won't moon you.
(audience laughing)
You didn't pay for that.
(intense drumming)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Francesca SugarArt asked me to.
So, if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did
Mel say that had the biggest
impact on you, what
was your favorite clip,
and what are you going
to take from this video
and immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to the guys
from VNR Media.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and for the
fun interview that we did
on your channel, it was
a blast and I'm excited
to see where your channel goes, guys.
- Our guest today is
Evan Carmichael and Evan,
he was recognized by Forbes
as one of the worlds top
40 social marketing talents.
Ink Magazine rated him as
one of the top 25 social
media keynote speakers you need to know.
And he had recently published
a book called Your One Word.
- So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(dramatic deep drumming)
- I have a pad of post it
notes, yes, post it notes,
next to my sink in my bathroom, why?
Well, because after I brush my teeth,
I haven't looked at my phone yet,
I take a post it note out
and I write the three things
I need to focus on today.
And then you know what I do with it?
I stick it on the back of my phone.
Now why would I do that?
Because I have my phone
with me all the time.
So if it's on the back of my phone,
I'm going to get a visual
cue to remind me and
keep it top of mind so
I stay focused on it.
How is it that you see
something larger for yourself?
Well, the first thing that you have to do,
the very first thing, is you
have to get out of the weeds.
Success for people are all in the weeds.
The busier you are, the
more you have going on.
You know that old saying
that everybody says,
don't work in your business,
work on your business.
But we're all in the weeds.
And the key to seeing
something larger for yourself
is getting out of the weeds.
And don't you feel like this dude?
I know I do, (mumbles)
wake up, brush your teeth,
make the coffee, feed the
kids, pack the lunches,
put them on the bus, get in the car,
text your friends, get some
coffee, arrive at work,
feign interest, answer
emails, update Facebook,
make cold calls, avoid
the meeting, look busy,
crunch some numbers, update
Facebook, get in the car,
go to carpool, feed
your kids, feed the dog,
check email, update
Facebook, kiss your husband,
climb into bed, fool
around, are you kidding?
I'm exhausted, turn off the lights.
(audience laughing)
I mean, I live in a two household...
Thank you.
Entrepreneurial family,
I'm exhausted, I'm busy.
How the heck am I going
to see something larger
for my life when I have a business to run,
when I have kids to take care of?
Well, you have to get out of the weeds.
And the truth is there's some good news,
and the goods news is I
heard that this pill that's
in development.
(people laughing)
Well, I know, I'm waiting for it too.
And you know, the problem
though is I think they're
going to have naming problems,
Forgetitol seems like
a bad name for a pill,
even though I might take it
now and again, so I thought
before we jump into how
you see something larger,
I need to yank you out
of the weeds first.
So I'm going to give you
my advice for what I do
in order to keep myself out of the weeds,
and you guys don't need
remedial personal development,
I got that, I just feel
obligated to give you some
actionable things to do
because if you don't plan
your week out before the week starts,
you're going to be in reactive mode.
You're going to be running around,
you're going to be chasing
down the biggest thing
that's happening in your life.
You're going to be constantly responding.
This is one of the most
important things that you can do,
if you're not married, if
you're not living with somebody,
do it for yourself, plan your
week, you know this all ready.
The first thing that you
need to do is you define
what success looks like for
you, and it's not 10 million
dollars in the bank, I'm sorry.
It needs to be something
bigger, a bigger--
- What if somebody says
it is 10 million dollars
in the bank to me?
- Well, you know, I mean,
the problem with saying it's
10 million dollars in the
bank is that when you finally
get to the 10 million dollars,
typically those people
feel pretty bankrupt because--
- And that's what you're
saying your (mumbles).
- Absolutely, absolutely.
And so, once you define it for yourself,
I think the key is how do you
then trick yourself, Donnie,
into feeling successful every single day?
I got a daughter that plays
lacrosse, she's nine years old.
If I said to her, I'm only
cheering for you when you
score a goal, how do you think
she'd feel during the game?
She wouldn't play very
well, that's for sure.
So you've got to figure out
how do you cheer for yourself,
and how do you feel successful
while you're playing
the game, because it's
not all about the goal.
- Are there any tools that
you want to share with us?
Give me a...
Today I want to feel
better inside, I'm at home,
I'm watching, I'm either
somebody that's got the millions
of dollars and is not feeling good,
or I don't have those
millions of dollars and
it's not feeling good, worrying
about the economy around me,
so give me (mumbles) session.
- Exactly what you need to
do, what you need to do is
you have to decide, okay,
this is where I'm going,
I'm going for the big
vision of what success is.
Now, do a head fake with
yourself and say, okay,
let's just say that I'm
actually all ready there,
I have the 10 million dollars in the bank,
I'm saving the world, whatever
it is that your version
of success is, what are three
things that I would change
about this day, today,
how would I live it today,
if I all ready had that stuff?
What time would I wake up?
Who's my first phone call to?
What did I eat for breakfast?
Start living as that success vision now.
(soft drumming)